here in a relatively small city in
Indiana there was an idea that is moving
a community forward Columbus is just
under fifty miles south of Indianapolis
almost straight south on interstate 65
and I believe the population is right
around 40,000 right now Columbus got the
name Athens of the Prairie from
something that was written for think was
The Saturday Evening Post sometime in
the 1960s it now has a really strong
reputation for modern and contemporary
architecture of the American Institute
of Architects for example lists it as
number six in the United States for the
quality of its architectural design and
all of this traces its roots to Joseph
Irwin Miller he commissioned Eero
Saarinen to design a vacation home from
the family
and about 1950 and shortly after that to
design a bank in Columbus for the
family's bank business and then very
shortly after that his residence on the
north side of Columbus we now call the
Miller house and garden a man who was
trying to build a better Cummins engine
company knew that he had to have a city
that would attract the kinds of people
that he needed to have their and retain
them engineers designers you know to
bring Cummins into a position of
leadership and so in the wake of
disappointing school buildings he made
an offer to the school board and said
here I'll give you a list of architects
and if you choose one from Melissa I'll
see that the architects fees are paid
and so this gave a gateway into better
design I think that the numbers probably
around 70 buildings now that work came
about through the aegis of the
architecture program but there have been
other organizations institutions that
have also I think taken inspiration from
this and build structures you know using
better modern and contemporary
architectural talents so we have both
seramins Elli and arrow we have
I am Pei there his work is in Columbus
this town is not you know an
architectural utopia and there's not
beauty at every turn by any means and
the fact that it's a very mixed
environment is something that
architectural critics and observers have
remarked on from the beginning of
journalism about this in the late 50s
and 1960s people always comment about
while you're rolling past you have the
ordinary kind of commercial buildings
and you see the ordinary sort of
ugliness that would exist in any kind of
town of this vintage and some people
even went as far as to say well this
should become part of the program itself
trying to have broader urban planning to
try to have greater control over the
entire environment and there was funding
of her an urban urban plan there but it
wasn't mr. Miller's wish ever to
completely control what Columbus was
going to look like if he said that it
was more important to him to create the
opportunity for this process than it was
to have any specific kind of product he
viewed it as experimental I think he was
quoted as saying a hundred years from
now we may be able to judge whether this
is a success or not but he was somebody
who put in for longer term thinking than
one often sees today